Texans Cinema emerges onto Thai soil for
the first time in 15 years
the first order of business to lay a
floral offering and to kneel in
gratitude before an image of the king
then waves and Smiles flanked by his
children he drank in the moment a quick
handshake with friends and supporters
two minutes of Freedom before being
whisked away Jackson China what has now
gone back inside the terminal to meet
the
to welcome him home after all of this
time
I am very happy I have always wanted to
see him coming home because maybe the
country will be better
we come here today and we are very happy
because he comes back to Thailand
voluntarily even if he has to go to
prison
and that was exactly where the former
prime minister was heading as crowds as
supporters waited outside the Supreme
Court Texan was driven inside
three guilty verdicts in his absence
eight years to be served
and then as more supporters chanted
outside he was driven into clongprem's
Central Prison to start his sentence
but how long was
inside
many think a deal has already been done
for an early release
might have made some sort of agreement
in order for him to be coming back and
in order for him to to sort of bring
some of the issues away from the
Parliament and from the Coalition those
issues include the formation of a new
government and finding a new prime
minister the debate that was taking
place in Parliament across town
after several months of stalemate
Texan's political allies per tie say
they've formed a ruling coalition
with votes coming in for their nominee
it was clear the military-backed Senate
approved set out how we sin a property
developing Tycoon confirmed as
Thailand's new prime minister
attacks in shinawat from his jail cell
may still be pulling the strings Tony
Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok
[Applause]